المره الاولى هذه التي تضيفون فيها
العوامل المناخيه للتهديدات والمره الاولى
التي نتحدث فيها عن التكنولوجيا والذكاء
الاصطناعي تم النظر الى انه ذكاء
الاصطناعي
بجله ايجابي هل هذا يعني انه خطوره الذكاء
الاصطناعي تهدد البشريه الان من اين واحد
تحديدا وماذا عن البيئه
البيئه بالتاكيد مساله ملاحظه اما فيما
يخص الذكاء الاصطناعي فكلنا نعرف بان هي
مساله مقلقه للحكومات وكذلك للانسانيه انا
عضو في
المجلس
وليس لدينا اي مصالحه وفقط ان نريد ان
تعيش الاجال المستقبليه حياه جيده
وبذلك فنحن سعداء جدا
للمشاركه في هذا الحدث
ونحن نقول ان هنالك فشل في القياده
الدوليه فعندما نفشل علينا
نذكرهم بفشلهم والان عليكم اتخاذ قرارات
افضل يعني هذا قد يكون مفهوم كثيرا
بالنسبه للاسلحه النوويه تطويرها بالنسبه
لعدم الاهتمام بالبيئه لكن فقط اريد ان
اركز قليلا على
نوعيه التهديد الذي نتوقعه من الذكاء
الاصطناعي هل هل ممكن ان تعطينا فكره
انا لست خبيرا في الذكاء الاصطناعي
وقرات الكثير عنه
وانا بالتاكيد اتبع الاجل العلميه فاذا ما
كان الذكاء الاصطناعي
يتجاوز القدره العقل البشري
فكيف نتعايش معه اذا ما كان الذكاء
الاصطناعي
حتى قدراتي وقوتي البشر تسليم مثل تهديدا
لهم وهذه مشكله كبيره اما من ذلك فعلينا
ان نركز بشكل اكبر على التهديدات النوويه
او التهديدات الوجوديه التي زادت خطورتها
مثلا الاسلحه النوويه والحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا اليوم
وتلك البيانات التي صدرت خلال الحرب
فكلنا نعرف ان الحربقه تتحول الى حرب
نوويه وكل هذه المسائل مرعبه جدا كما ان
هنالك الكوارث الطبيعيه فنحن نشهد
تبعات التغير المناخيه عبر الكوارث
الطبيعيه وحتى الجائحه التي ذكرتها قبل
قليل